una reunión celebrada en berlín podría
marcar un giro contra la lucha de las
enfermedades infecciosas en áfrica la
sociedad valiente que creó la primera
vacuna de la tecnología de adn mensajero
contra el commit 19 ahora se interesa
por la lucha contra la tuberculosis y el
paludismo dos biológicos que usan la
misma tecnología se proyectan para
luchar contra estas enfermedades y la
firma alemana quiere producirlas en
ruanda y senegal
vayan text adelantó y se decidió en
colaboración con los socios africanos y
la comisión europea llevar la tecnología
del adn mensajero a áfrica la tecnología
haré en mensajeros conocida por combatir
el kobe pero también tiene un enorme
potencial para combatir otras
enfermedades como el paludismo o la
tuberculosis
y mucho
el paludismo cobra la vida de cerca de
400.000 personas cada año en áfrica por
eso para senegal el anuncio de valiente
que es un alivio actualmente sólo el 1
por ciento de las vacunas que se aplican
en el continente se producen allí yo
quisiera señalar que hoy es un día
histórico en nuestro combate para el
acceso a la vacuna la vacunación
equitativa en áfrica como lo habíamos
dicho
bayón tecno es la única que quiere
expandir la utilización de la tecnología
de la rn mensajero en la lucha contra
nuevas enfermedades modernas hará
pruebas en las próximas semanas de una
vacuna con aire de mensajero contra el
vih